hmm
[Musik]
ja
unser sexleben
durch den winter gehen
ja
damit erweisen
jetzt
[Musik]
ja guten tag meine damen und herren die
bundeskanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsidenten
ihre unterredung beendet die kanzlerin
der erste bürgermeister hepp
tschentscher und ministerpräsident söder
informieren sich jetzt darüber ja meine
damen und herren die regierungschefs und
chefin der länder
und ich habe wieder einmal über die
gewaltigen herausforderungen beraten vor
die die krone ab anime hier alle
bürgerinnen und bürger aber auch alle
ebenen unseres föderalen landes gestellt
haben und eine herausforderung ist das
für die es ja keinerlei vorlage gibt
keine ist historischen erfahrungswerte
und in der wir dank der arbeit der
wissenschaftler jeden tag dazulernen
aber eben auch lernen müssen
ich bin sehr froh dass wir diese
beratungen jetzt sehr regelmäßig etwa
alle 14 tage durchführen
sie helfen uns gemeinsam vorzugehen
sie helfen uns beschlüsse im sinne einer
gemeinsamen strategie zu fassen aber
natürlich sind wir ein föderales land
das heißt es gibt regionale abweichungen
und das wird auch angesichts regionaler
unterschiede in einem land wie
deutschland immer so sein aber ich
glaube es ist damit interessen der
menschen der bürgerinnen und bürger dass
es für ganz deutschland eine strategie
gibt und eine zielsetzung bei dieser
pandemie und ich möchte das hat dieses
ziel noch einmal wiederholen da es weder
ein medikament noch einen impfstoff
gegen dieses virus gibt geht es immer
darum die ausbreitung zu verlangsamen
und zwar so weit zu verlangsamen dass
unser gesundheitssystem unsere
krankenhäuser die schwer zahl der
schwererkrankten corona erkranken
bewältigen kann und jedem patienten die
bestmögliche medizinische versorgung
geben kann
das ist uns bis jetzt gelungen
wir alle haben zusammen in den letzten
wochen viel erreicht und ich möchte noch
einmal allen
duncan die dazu beigetragen haben
entweder indem die regeln befolgt wurden
und werden in dem einschränkungen von
den menschen auf sich genommen wurden
eigene interessen für das wohl aller
immer wieder hinten angestellt wurden
viele tun das weiter und ich bitte auch
alle es weiter zu tun aber ich möchte
heute den dank erweitern und zwar auch
auf all diejenigen die bei dem
hochfahren unseres öffentlichen lebens
von wirtschaft von sozialen bereichen
und öffentlichen leben die sich darüber
gedanken machen wie das geschehen kann
und ist beeindruckt mich sehr
die branche für branche lebensbereich
für lebensbereich konzepte erarbeitet
werden die mit viel liebe zum detail
genau auf die wichtigen dinge achten
die ja bei der bekämpfung dieses virus
so entscheidend sind nämlich distanz zu
halten sich zu schützen masken zu tragen
ob das im arbeitsschutz ist oder aber
auch im gesellschaftlichen leben und
diese umsichtigen arbeitsschutz konzepte
mit abstand und hygieneregeln oder die
vorschläge der kultusministerkonferenz
der ju ministerkonferenz die vorschläge
der religionsgemeinschaften die wir
jetzt alle gesehen haben sind ein
beispiel dafür wie sozusagen der
zukünftige alltag unter den bedingungen
der pandemie gestaltet wird und das geht
sehr gut voran
wenn diese konzepte dann ausgearbeitet
sind dann bleibt es jeweils natürlich
die verantwortung der politik zu
entscheiden wann es wieder losgehen kann
und das sind schwierige entscheidungen
das sind schwierige abwägungen da gibt
es auch keinen automatismus sondern wir
müssen jedes mal vorsichtig auf die
gesamtlage blicken und immer wieder
haben wir die große verantwortung
alles was wir in unserer macht haben zu
tun damit es keinen rückfall in eine
schwierigere phase gibt sondern dass wir
schritt für schritt vorankommen
wir haben es ja bis jetzt geschafft die
dynamik der ausbreitung des virus zu
bremsen und das muss auch wieder weiter
unser leitgedanke sein zumal uns die
wissenschaftler der führenden
wissenschaftsorganisationen ja auch
immer wieder sagen dass wir daran
arbeiten sollen und müssen die zahl der
infizierten auch wenn sie heute schon
viel geringer ist noch weiter nach unten
zu bringen und es geht vor allen dingen
auch darum dass wir die infektionsketten
nachvollziehen können hier hat der
öffentliche gesundheitsdienst
hervorragendes geleistet und ich möchte
mich auch bei allen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern dieser öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienste ganz herzlich
bedanken
sie haben sozusagen wirklich viel von
unserer zukunft im augenblick in ihrer
hand und deshalb haben wir sich auch
unterstützt und gestärkt jede lockerung
der bisherigen einschränkung führt
natürlich dazu dass menschen sich wieder
mehr in der öffentlichkeit bewegen
einander mehr begegnen dass innenstädte
und auch verkehrsmittel sich fühlen und
deshalb müssen wir die notwendigen
auswirkungen auf mögliche neue
infektionen ständig im blick behalten
und ich glaube da sind sich bund und
länder auch einig das kommt auch in
unserem beschluss zum ausdruck es bleibt
also unbedingt notwendig dass wir
diszipliniert bleiben dass wir den
sicherheitsabstand waren und die
hygieneregeln einhalten
wir werden bei allen kommenden maßnahmen
auch immer wieder gut abwägen was es
bedeutet dass gesundheitlich was hat das
für die sozialen zusammenhalt unserer
gesellschaft an auswirkungen und was
sind vor allen dingen auf die
wirtschaftlichen aspekte
all das muss sorgsam mit einer abgewogen
werden und wir wissen und das haben wir
heute auch zum ausdruck gebracht sollte
die kurve der infektion wieder steiler
werden dann müssen bund und länder auch
so aufgestellt sein dass wir das
frühzeitig bemerken dass wir also ein
warnsystem haben und gegebenenfalls auch
bereits zu reagieren
ich bin sehr dankbar dass wir uns
darüber einig sind deshalb sollen die
heutigen beratungen ein zwischenschritt
denn die zwölf bis vierzehn tage die es
ja dauert das wir wissen was das ganze
für auswirkungen auf unser
infektionsgeschehen hat diese tage
werden erst am 6 mai vorbei sein wenn
wir uns an die öffnung von geschäften
erinnern deshalb werden wir auch nächste
woche bereits wieder tagen
und deshalb haben wir heute einzelne
beschlüsse gefasst aber wir werden vor
allen dingen in der nächsten woche noch
mal ein weitergehendes paket
verabschieden
heute standen im zentrum noch einmal
dieses bekenntnis dass wir
großveranstaltungen bis zum 31 august
nicht werden zu lassen können das wird
etwas spezifiziert größere
sportveranstaltungen volksfeste mit
zuschauern größere konzerte festivals
dorf staatsstraßen und weinen und
schützenfeste und kirmesveranstaltungen
und diese werden also auch noch für
längere zeit untersagt bleiben müssen
ich möchte mich bei den kirchen und
religionsgemeinschaften bedanken die ein
hervorragendes konzept vorgelegt haben
hier liegt die verantwortung bei den
ländern aber es wird unter den maßregeln
die dort ausgearbeitet wurden gemeinsam
ausgearbeitet wurden mit den kirchen und
religionsgemeinschaften wieder gottes
kind dienste geben können
wir haben uns entschlossen mit auflagen
auch spielplätze wieder öffnen zu können
das werden die länder auch im einzelnen
dann entscheiden und unter auflagen auch
die kultureinrichtungen wie museen
ausstellung galerien gedenkstätten oder
zoologische und botanische gärten
wir werden am 65 dann die konzepte der
kultusminister jugendminister und
sportminister auswerten und sehr klare
entscheidungen fällen in welcher folge
und in welcher art und weise schule kita
wieder möglich sind und auch unter
gegebenen bedingungen natürlich
bestimmte sportliche betätigung und wir
haben darüber gesprochen dass wir
natürlich auch anderen branchen
perspektiven geben sollten
und deshalb werden die zuständigen
fachminister konferenzen beauftragt bis
zu der konferenz die auf den 6 mai folgt
da haben wir das datum noch nicht genau
festgelegt dann auch
aktiven und rahmenbedingungen für die
schrittweise öffnung von gastronomie und
tourismus angeboten und für die weiteren
kultureinrichtungen vorzubereiten
immer vorausgesetzt natürlich dass das
infektionsgeschehen das zulässt wir
haben heute die arbeitslosenzahlen
gehört und die zahl der menschen die in
kurzarbeit sind wir wissen dass es
tiefgehende wirtschaftliche auswirkungen
gibt die wir versuchen abzufedern
trotzdem natürlich sind sie mit großen
großen herzen für beschäftigte für
inhaber von unternehmen für
selbstständige und viele andere
verbunden und deshalb haben wir diese
dinge im blick aber ich bin der festen
überzeugung auch die interessen der
wirtschaft auch die interessen der
sozialen kontakte verfolgen wir dann am
besten wenn wir einen blick darauf
werfen dass wir schritte voran gehen
können bei der zulassung von mehr
kontakten aber nicht wieder zurückgehen
müssen und deshalb bleibt vorsicht das
gebot und die einhaltung der hygiene
maßnahmen auch wir haben alle damen und
herren vor bundeskanzlerin corona hält
und zwei den atem und zwar nicht nur
woche für woche sondern jeden tag alle
politisch verantwortlichen in
deutschland überlegen sich man kann
nicht anders an rund um die uhr was der
richtige weg der richtige zeitpunkt ist
auf welchen themen feldern und die wir
am ende diese größte herausforderung
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg für unser
land meistern können was das positive
ist die zahlen zu krone haben sich
deutlich stabilisiert
ich kann das allein ein bundesland wie
bayern sagen wir waren am anfang mit am
stärksten betroffen
aufgrund der grenznähe wir hatten zu
beginn der krise steigerungsraten von
jedem tag von 25 28 prozent wir liegen
zum beispiel heute nach rk ii bei 0,6
einem sehr stabilen niedrigen wert und
das macht uns zwar optimistisch aber es
bleibt die sorge trotzdem da denn wir
wissen nicht was kommt und ob die selten
zu lange kein medikament kein impfstoff
da es droht jederzeit die gefahr eines
rückfalls oder einer zweiten welle
wir haben also bislang ein stückweit
glück gehabt und wir haben klug agiert
die geduld der menschen hat enorm viel
dazu beigetragen dass deutschland sich
stabilisiert hat aber ich glaube auch
das rechtzeitige frühzeitige und
geschlossene und entschlossene handeln
auch der politik in deutschland im
moment finde ich entbrennen gebacken die
eigentlich angesichts der situation ich
zum teil nicht nachvollziehen kann
im moment werden nur die fragen gestellt
welche folgen hat der lockdown gehabt
welches schwierigen auswirkungen
ich bin immer die gegenfrage zu stellen
welche folgen hätte es gegeben hätten
wir das nicht gemacht was wäre in
unserem land los gewesen hätten wir es
verschlafen
kein land fast kein land der welt hat
sich anders verhalten und die dies
anders gemacht haben müssen alle
nachjustieren mit erheblichen schäden
unser gesundheitssystem ist oft
geschmäht wurde hat bislang den
absoluten stresstest bestanden
deutschland hat diesen stresstest
bislang gut bestanden beachtung der ist
noch nicht vorbei corona ist ein
marathon bei den wm in den nicht wissen
wo das ziel ist und wie lang der lauf
dauert so dass wir nicht obwohl mehr
gute zeit überbrückt haben plötzlich
aufhören zu laufen oder uns ausruhen
können
wir brauchen bei der maximale
konzentration und aufmerksamkeit auf
diese frage auf die klärung und auf die
weitere strategie wie geht's mit krone
weiter wenn ich das noch sagen darf wir
müssen die wirtschaftlichen fragen im
blick haben
aber dabei die ethischen nicht vergessen
debatten über die frage wie lange jemand
leben soll sind fragen die ich nicht nur
für unangebracht halte sondern für
gefährlich übrigens genau bei der
debatte standen letztlich in italien wer
darf beatmet werden wer nicht wer hat
noch ein recht länger zu leben wenn über
solche fragen in deutschland reden dann
ist es nicht nur ein falscher schritt
ist ein schwerer unfall in diskussionen
die wir auf keinen fall zulassen sollten
also der wichtigste rat ist vorsicht ist
umsicht das heißt aber nicht ausblenden
dass im land stattfindet wir sind nicht
stur aber wir sind verantwortlich
und deswegen brauchen wir weiteren rat
der wissenschaftler
wenn heute max planck reitens und hellem
holz also drei der international
angesehensten wissenschaftsinstitutionen
der welt
die überlänge welt tätig sind wenn die
deutschland bescheinigen dass der weg im
moment der richtige war
dann sollten wir das positive ist moment
hinnehmen dass psychologen ihre meinung
weiterentwickeln ist selbstverständlich
weil das virus entwickelt sich auch und
erkenntnisse aus der ganzen welt müssen
zusammen verwalten werden
sogar politiker so ein ab und an gestern
was anderes sagen als heute und insofern
gibt es da auch keine verteufelung
sondern ein miteinander leben deswegen
und es ist auch heute wieder bestandteil
gewesen
wir hatten eine sehr sachliche
diskussionen wie fandet sehr
tiefgreifende diskussionen auf
verantwortungsbewusste ist es wichtig
dass wir am ende aber an ist klarmachen
wir wollen zeitachsen eröffnen wir
wollen perspektiven geben aber wir
beenden nicht aus was passieren kann
wenn wir zu schnell agieren wenn wir
fehler machen wenn wir es überstürzen
und dabei unsere eigenen füße stolpern
mein eindruck ist frau bundeskanzlerin
europa schaut eigentlich etwas bewundern
auf deutschland manchmal auch aber das
verwundert auf deutschland also wie gut
es gelaufen ist bisher und wie schnell
wir jetzt schon wieder glauben dass
dieses problem keine rolle spielt ich
habe übrigens verständnis für alle
ich habe verständnis für alle bürger
nicht sagen ich möchte wieder so leben
wie vorher
ich möchte gerne die gastronomie gehen
ich möchte in urlaub fahren natürlich
das würden die alle ganz selbst wir
spüren auch den wirtschaftlichen druck
wir erleben dass verschiedene gruppen
auf uns zugehen und sagen macht jetzt
mehr macht jetzt schneller aber die
aufgabe für uns ist alles
zusammenzubringen aus ungeduld
kreativität zu entwickeln und auf der
anderen seite damit mit konzepten die
perspektivisch sind zeitachsen zu
definieren
diese zeitachsen aber auch so zu sehen
dass es schneller gehen kann wenn es
besser wird aber langsamer wenn es
schlechter wird
das ist glaube ich mach das ganz
entscheidende also eine atmende
strategie in der entwicklung
besonnenheit ist unsere aufgabe
keine experimente mit der gesundheit der
menschen was sie heute gemacht haben da
gibt es sicherlich bei der einer anderen
frage in unterschiedlichen akzent der
eine wollte mehr der andere wollte ich
das weniger aber es ist glaube ich an
rahmen hat tschentscher das kann man
sagen
in dem sich alle wiederfinden können und
indem wir uns ja woche für woche war der
bewegen das ziel ist es transparent zu
machen
auflagen zu verbinden und auch natürlich
regionale besonderheiten zu akzeptieren
also in einigen bundesländern wird man
andere entscheidung treffen in
gerichtsurteile sind in einigen geht man
vorsichtiger und ich sage es für bayern
zum beispiel das was heute beschlossen
wurde muss natürlich jetzt aufgearbeitet
werden muss in den nächsten
kabinettssitzungen geraten werden wir
werden nächste woche den entsprechenden
fahrplan in bayern zu machen weil zum
beispiel beim thema spielplätze
da ist die frage wie in welcher form wie
gesichert das muss man dann diskutieren
ich will mal sagen was mich noch ganz
besonders wichtig ist die
wirtschaftlichste eine teil
da wird umfangreich nachgedacht wir
haben bei gastronomie und handel wenn
wir nächste woche die perspektiven
erleben da gibt es ja schon vorarbeiten
und ich sage doch der gastronomie des
dehoga und natürlich auch der
gewerkschaft vida in der steht tolle
interview die konzepte aber das ist die
größte herausforderung weil in der
gastronomie mundschutz wenig sinn macht
und distanz gebot was das zentrale
element ist und bleibt angesichts von
alkohol und sagen wir zumindest schwerer
konsequent umsetzt aber die realität des
lebens konzepte die wir machen müssen
nicht nur auf dem papier bestehen
sondern auch in realität aber ich sage
schon uns macht die familie die meisten
sorgen nächste woche ist ein muttertag
beispielsweise natürlich ist es wichtig
dass wir bei senioren und pflegeheimen
die nach wie vor die gros der
infektologe herausforderung sind einen
weg finden können dass man sich wieder
etwas mehr besuchen kann dass man mutter
großmutter besuchen sehen kann
dafür gibt es möglichkeiten mit festen
kontaktpersonen der spielplatz ist
eigentlich nicht das wichtigste sondern
wichtiges dass wir für kita und schulen
den weg finden und dort übrigens einen
weg finden der den besorgnissen der
eltern die große sorgen wie die kinder
der gefährdet sind ernst nehmen aber
auch den pädagogen pädagogen eine chance
geben die auch zu risikogruppen gehören
so die größte und sportlichste
herausforderung sein da ein konzept zum
mit breiteste unterstützung und das
gleiche gilt für die gleich kita schule
ist mir noch wichtig zu sagen
ist auch wichtig dass man die zeitachse
so definiert dass wir nicht chaos an den
schulen haben und wieder zurück drehen
müssen also schulen schließen müssen
obwohl sie gerade es eröffnet haben und
das ganze anderen zeitachse bringen mit
den mitteln für den ferien haben heute
gute beschlüsse zu chores diensten
gefasst ist ein wichtiger beitrag wie
finde haben wir haben jetzt auch noch
mal das thema kultur erweitert was sie
zu sehen beispielsweise betrifft auch da
muss jetzt im lauf der nächsten woche
dann bevor alles geöffnet werden kann
müssen dann die entsprechende hygiene
konzepte da sein
das gilt übrigens auch für tiergarten da
müssen wir mit den kommunen darüber
reden in bayern in münchen insbesondere
und in nürnberg wie man da
beispielsweise natürlich nur außen nicht
innen indem man auch beispielsweise
online kartenverkauf macht das muss noch
die kommunen an der stelle bereden
letzter punkt die heutigen beschlüsse
die wir getroffen haben sind wie die
bundeskanzlei sagt wieder ein schritt in
richtung normalität aber normalität mit
corona eine andere normalität gibt es
auf absehbare zeit nicht das wird nicht
ewig so sein
wir werden da schon durch diese krise
kommen
wir haben bislang das land gut durch die
krise geführt und wir werden auch da bin
ich überzeugt das land aus dieser krise
gemeinsam herausführen
aber geduld geduld und konsequenz
zusammen glaube ich sind der richtige
ratgeber besonnenheit stadt lobbyismus
und transparenz und nachvollziehbarkeit
in den punkten wird die nächsten wochen
richtig sein also wir müssen schauen und
ich finde dass uns heute besser gelungen
als manches mal zuvor stückwerk zu
vermeiden und eine langfristige
perspektive zusammen perspektive heißt
ein bisschen noch licht am ende des
tunnels zu sehen sondern wir kriegen wir
das woche für woche weiter
und da noch mal danke an die an den
kollegen aus hamburg und die anderen
bundesländer war glaube ich insgesamt
eine gute diskussion auch wenn die
unterschiede einfach von der realität da
sind nun zum schluss oder bundeskanzler
tatsächlich auch die internationale
stimme der vernunft ist
ja wie gesagt wir haben besprochen dass
wir alle spüren in deutschland
je erfolgreicher wir sind mit der
verlangsamung der infektions
geschwindigkeit und so stärker tritt
jetzt tag für tag der dringende wunsch
der bürgerinnen und bürger in den
vordergrund dass wir weitere schritte
gehen zu einem wieder normaleren
öffentlichen leben und gleich wurde das
war wirklich die die durchgängige
haltung heute in der diskussion
wir dürfen unsere strategie die
erfolgreich ist jetzt nicht verlassen
und die strategie besteht darin dass wir
schrittweise vorgehen und das wir
kontrolliert vorgehen dass wir jeden
schritt jeden größeren schritt
hintergehen kontrollieren
über einen entsprechenden zeitabstand
und die infektions daten die wir dann
erhalten und das hat eben die
entscheidung heute geprägt keinen großen
neuen schritt sondern dies am 65 also in
der kommenden woche erörtern
es wird dann gehen über die dinge die
vereinbart sind die als konzept schon
vorliegen ist dann gehen am sport kita
um die schule und weitere schritte in
diesen feldern und heute haben wir uns
eben beschränkt auf kleinere bereinigen
de maßnahmen einzelpunkte in denen wir
davon ausgehen können dass sie kein
nennenswertes größeres infektionsrisiko
mit sich bringen wenn wir die maßnahmen
einhalten mit denen wir diese schritte
verknüpft haben und insofern ein sehr
gutes ergebnis dinge die schon
beschlossen waren oder vorbereitet waren
wie die erleichterte religionsausübung
kombiniert mit bereinigen den punkten
die zum teil in einem ländern sowieso
schon in kraft fahren und die ein
voraussichtlich nur sehr geringes risiko
mit sich bringen
die infektions situation zu
verschlechtern sind heute beschlossen
worden und werden dann einvernehmlich
gesagt in der kommenden woche werden wir
im lichte der dann vorliegenden daten
über die nächsten oder die nächsten
großen schritte sprechen dann kommen wir
zu ihren fragen herr blank von dpa fängt
an
sie hatten es in ihrer stellungnahme
gesagt über gastronomie und tourismus
soll entschieden werden nicht mehr
nächsten sondern in der darauffolgenden
sitzung dessen sind wir kurz vor den
pfingstferien wenn sie einschätzen
müssten heute die leute müssen ja auch
buchen
glauben sie dass überhaupt im sommer
noch ein urlaub außerhalb von
deutschland vielleicht in italien oder
spanien möglich ist und verknüpft damit
die frage an den ministerpräsidenten
kann es da eine sonderrolle für
österreich vielleicht geben danke also
ich kann nur zu dingen wirklich profunde
aussagen machen die ich überblicken kann
das kann heute nicht überblickt werden
sie ich möchte auch noch mal darauf
hinweisen bei uns ist ja die diskussion
schon auf einem sehr komfortablen niveau
wir reden jetzt darüber wann machen wir
die schulen auf die kitas auf wir
erarbeiten konzepte für die zukunft wann
kann auch im bereich restaurants und
hotels vielleicht wieder etwas
stattfinden in einigen europäischen
ländern ist noch der totale lockdown
wenn ich an unsere französischen
nachbarn denke bis zum 11
und da jetzt darüber zu sprechen wie die
europäischen reisebewegungen im sommer
stattfinden ist nicht das thema das
jetzt im augenblick schon auf der
tagesordnung steht ich kann für uns nur
sagen für deutschland alles daran setzen
das sagen dass ja auch die
wissenschaftler so weiter zu machen wir
sind jetzt bei durchschnittlichen
infektionszahlen für ganz deutschland
von unter 1500 fällen dort mehrere tage
lang wir haben 400 gesundheitsämter wir
haben die infektion sehr unterschiedlich
verteilt aber wir haben die
gesundheitsämter so gestärkt dass im
grunde die infektionsketten
nachvollziehbar sind wir gewinnen auch
viel mehr einsicht wo ist ein geschehen
in einem pflegeheim wo es etwas in einem
krankenhaus wo sind es noch die
nachwirkungen der skiurlauber und wir
müssen jetzt lernen
wie sich auch unsere zusätzlichen
hygienemaßnahmen die tatsache dass im
öffentlichen raum sehr viel masken oder
mundschutz getragen wird wie die
tatsache dass die menschen sich an die
distanzregelung gewöhnt haben wie macht
sich das bemerkbar zu der zeit vorher
dann wären wir als erstes mal sehen was
tut sich regional neuer phase würde
erreicht werden wenn wir jetzt innerhalb
deutschlands wieder touristische reisen
zu laufen dann sind natürlich wieder die
ausstände vollkommen miteinander
durcheinandergebracht
auch die restaurants sind deshalb so
problematisch nicht weil wir der
gastronomie nicht wünschen und den
menschen sich wünschen dass sie essen
gehen können sondern dass an selbst wenn
die tische zwei meter abstand haben an
einem tisch geht natürlich nicht
kontrollieren können sitzt dort eine
familie dann ist das vollkommen
unproblematisch
oder aber sitzen dort menschen die sich
aus ganz unterschiedlichen haus stellen
begegnen
und jedes mal müssen wir lernen wie
wirkt sich das aus wie weit haben die
hygiene maßnahmen gegriffen und ich
glaube das ist das klügste und zum
schluss auch schnellste vorgehen und
deshalb ist die frage kann man innerhalb
europas reisen jetzt noch nicht auf der
agenda das muss ich ganz einfach so
sagen kann also sage also die
entscheidung die grenzen offen oder 16
trifft der punkt an der stelle
ich kann nur eines sagen sollte am ende
möglicherweise innerhalb deutschlands
das reisen möglich sein kann ich jedem
sagen wir im süden fährt man muss nicht
nach österreich fahren da kann auch in
bayern
dann kann man wenn es dann möglich jetzt
wegen haben oder man kann bis man nicht
im süden fährt und kann man da in bayern
möglich
damit ist es schon geklärt wo man fährt
oder südwest ist dabei die nächste frage
frau kunz von der rheinischen post
apropos west
jüngeren vergangenheit durch betrug sich
selbst etwas in schieflage gebracht hat
fordert jetzt wieder hilfe der
steuerzahler haben die eine aussicht auf
kaufprämien herrn den herr nun bis zum
10 mai weiter gelten
ja das ist ja das übliche verfahren das
die galten im allgemeinen bis zum
dritten mai und wir haben auch heute den
beschluss wieder so aufgebaut dass alles
was nicht extra erwähnt wird weiter so
gilt wie wir es früher beschlossen haben
und die allgemeinverfügung werden jetzt
in die meisten ländern aber markus söder
und tschentscher können das besser sagen
natürlich noch einmal weitergeschrieben
bis zum zehnten mal wir treffen
sozusagen sechsten mal wieder und dann
wird man das wiedersehen das ist
jedesmal jetzt so passiert worden
es passiert also der chef des
kanzleramtes herr braun wollte nur
deutlich machen dass die nicht am
dritten mai enden sondern dass sie
fortgeschrieben werden darauf haben wir
uns heute auch verständigt und dass die
das gespräch mit der automobilindustrie
ambulant so ist ein gespräch das wir
jetzt ja regelmäßig führen das hat mir
im übrigen schon vor der hungerkrise in
einem etwas größeren format begonnen und
das war ausdruck der tatsache dass die
automobilindustrie eine wichtige
kernbranche in deutschland ist von der
sehr sehr viele arbeitsplätze abhängen
und wir haben natürlich ein großes
interesse daran wenn es um die
wiederbelebung der wirtschaft geht dass
die automobilindustrie auch gute chancen
hat wir werden am dienstag keine
entscheidung über anreize zum autokauf
fällen weil wir
das einbetten werden in ein
gesamtprogramm zur belebung der
wirtschaftlichen tätigkeit und da wird
sicherlich die automobilbranche auch
eine rolle spielen
sie wird es im übrigen auch auf
europäischer ebene spielen dann auch
dort reden wir über ein recovery fand
also jeder hat gesagt wir haben jetzt
rettungsmaßnahmen in höhe von 500
milliarden dort genauso wie mir
nationaler rettungsmaßnahmen haben und
jetzt geht es dann auch um die
perspektive was passiert wenn die
wirtschaft wieder anlaufen soll auch da
wird auf europäischer ebene die
automobilindustrie eine rolle spielen
denn nicht nur deutsche arbeitsplätze
hängen davon ab sondern auch viele
arbeitsplätze in spanien den
osteuropäischen ländern usw aber
dienstag sind dazu keine zeitnahen
entscheidungen zu erwarten
aber ich glaube wir haben wenn man sich
heute mal die arbeitslosenzahlen
anschaut die kurzarbeit zahlen über zehn
millionen menschen haben kurzarbeit da
kann man erstens sagen das ist sehr gut
dass wir solche reserven auch bei
unserer bundesagentur für arbeit haben
da haben möchte ich auch den
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern danken
diese ganzen anträge zu bearbeiten in
kurzer zeit das sind etwa 14 mal mehr
menschen die als die die das
normalerweise machen
sie haben sich in kurzer zeit
eingearbeitet um menschen auch eine
perspektive zu geben
aber das zeigt auch dass wir natürlich
so weit das infektionsgeschehen dass
zunächst alles tun sollten um die
wirtschaft wieder auf die beine zu
bringen dazu gehört die
automobilindustrie will diese grenzen zu
wissen dass die die großen auto länder
niedersachsen baden württemberg und
bayern sicht tagen abstimmen
wir haben am montag jetzt ganz ohne
videokonferenz- und dann da auch noch
mal drüber reden
wir sind uns aber ziemlich einig darüber
dass wir für die automobil nicht nur für
automobil als solches sondern für eine
verbindung von automobilität aber von
der herausforderung der technologischen
des klimaschutz natürlich ein konzept
brauchen wir waren uns auch immer alle
darüber klar die haben jetzt eine phase
das sagen wir das überbrücken es auch
das ist kurzarbeit so wichtig das sind
die kredit- und bürgschaftsprogramme so
wichtig und wir werden dann sollte alles
sich zu stabilisieren wie es im moment
ja aussicht und sieht was wir hoffen
brauchen wir ein wirtschaftskonzept noch
das durchstarten und auch der der
animation der stimulation der wirtschaft
um das in gang zu setzen zumal wir als
exportnation natürlich extrem davon
abhängig sind
in anderen ländern ähnliche
entwicklungen sind wir bei uns muss man
sagen das ganze angesprochen wenn der
usa markt nicht sich entwickelt wenn in
europa sich wenig bewegt dann müssen wir
auch umgekehrt überlegen was können in
deutschland noch tun um nachfrage im
binnenkonjunktur anzukurbeln
oder braucht es viele ideen eine davon
ist sicherlich der automobilität zu
unterstützen sie wissen ich bin für eine
solche innovation prämie
wir warten jetzt mal ein auto ländern
mit dem bund ob und wie das umgesetzt
werden kann
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben ja gerade
eine eine art lanze gebrochen für die
wissenschaft und deren stetig neue
erkenntnisse können sie die kritik
nachvollziehen die sich ja an die
politik und auch an sie persönlich
richtet dass sie aufgrund
unterschiedlicher wissenschaftlicher
erkenntnisse natürlich auch immer wieder
neue ziel ansagen gemacht haben also
verdopplung szenen versammlungssaal 14
dann war plötzlich die ärzte wichtig
jetzt ist eigentlich gar keine zahlen
mehr wichtig können sie das
nachvollziehen und habe ich sie richtig
verstanden dass ein neues qualitatives
ziel jetzt ist dass man die
gesundheitsämter so ausstattet
einerseits und die fallzahl andererseits
so niedrig kriegt dass man das jeweils
zusammenbringt dahingehend dass die
infektionsketten verlässlich immer
wieder unterbrochen werden können und
eine kleine zusatzfrage noch bitte
trifft es zu dass der französische
präsident sie kontaktiert hat mit dem
ansinnen nachdem die franzosen die
französische erste liga abgesagt haben
dass sie auch die bundesliga stornieren
sollen
habe ich überhaupt noch nie wasser
formuliert habe regelmäßigen kontakt mit
dem französischen präsidenten aber davon
habe ich nichts gehört
ich will als erstes mal sagen das ich
mich sehr freue dass deutschland
herausragende wissenschaftler in dem
bereich der virologie aber auch der
epidemiologie hat auf deren stimme wir
hören können und auf die ihre stimme
auch viele andere außerhalb deutschlands
führen wir haben immerhin den forschern
drosten gehabt der den ersten test
entwickelt hat für das kroner virus und
da kann man sich schon freuen wenn es
einer ist der sozusagen in deutschland
arbeitet denn all diese tests werden wir
ja in einer ziemlich schwierigen lage
dass das kennzeichen von wissenschaft
ist darf man immer wieder die neuesten
erkenntnisse auch transparent macht und
deutlich macht und wir haben zum
beispiel brennendes interesse daran
herauszubekommen
sie wirkt dieses virus auf kinder weil
davon natürlich sehr sehr viele
entscheidungen abhängen und da haben wir
jetzt sehr viele studien keine ist so
dass man jetzt sagen würde das ist schon
das ende sondern da gibt es jeden tag
neue erkenntnisse es wäre aber auch ganz
schlimm wenn die wissenschaftler nicht
das was sie wissen publizieren und dann
muss daraus eine konsolidierte meinung
erarbeitet werden aber es kann natürlich
sein dass man es noch drei monaten noch
nicht weiß abschließend
es kann auch seinen sohn virus kann sich
auch verändern das kann ganz
außergewöhnliche dinge geben die
mutieren und plötzlich hat man andere
erkenntnisse hat man am anfang hatte das
heißt damit müssen wir leben das ist
teil unserer aufgeklärten gesellschaft
und es wäre nichts schlimmer als wenn
wissenschaftler uns ihre letzten
erkenntnissen nicht mit tandem
entscheiden müssen wir politisch abwägen
aus den verschiedenen
wissenschaftsdisziplinen die
erkenntnisse zusammen nehmen maßstäbe
bilden keine überforderung des
gesundheitssystems aber natürlich wollen
wir auch dass uns
wirtschaft möglichst gut arbeiten kann
im übrigen gibt es länder in europa
da ist die hälfte der wirtschaft gar
nicht tätig wir haben im grunde
wirtschaftliche tätigkeit nie verboten
jetzt zu den zahlen um einen sachverhalt
wie eine solche pandemie oder epidemie
zu beschreiben kann es durchaus drei
kenngrößen geben von denen keine einzige
falsch ist am anfang war das unheimlich
einprägsam dass man gesagt hat in zwei
tagen verdoppelt sich die zahl dann in
sechs tagen verdoppelt sich die zahl
dann waren es die zehn tagen warum bin
ich auf 14 tage gegangen weil wir
plötzlich festgestellt haben dass die
patienten die in den beatmungs betten
liegen nicht zwei wochen dort liegen
sondern im durchschnitt drei bis vier
wochen dort ging es könnte aber nicht
wissen als wir noch keine warten muss
kann es jetzt gemacht
wir haben am anfang ganz viele
krankenhausbetten normal gebaut
hier in berlin ist sonder ganzen klinik
gearbeitet worden und wir haben
intensivbetten verstärkt irgendwann
haben wir gemerkt mit der normalen
krankenhaus kapazitäten kommen wir klar
wenn es einen engpass gibt haben bei den
intensivbetten so jetzt wahr ist
natürlich ein unterschied wenn ich
nachher mal bei 14 15 tagen will und auf
einem wir haben angefangen daran hatten
wir die ersten schließungen haben wir
gemacht haben wir 3000 infizierte gehabt
binnen weniger tage waren wir bei 9000
dabei 18.000 heute sind wir aktuell bei
40.000 infizierten und einer gesamtzeit
von 1 150 160000 die verdopplung zahl
also ein punkt aber immer für jeden
epidemiologen der faktor etwas was
existiert hat es gibt überhaupt kein
epidemiologen der faktor arbeit der ist
nicht neu erfunden jetzt auch nicht von
mir neu ins spiel gebracht ich hatte
damals nur gedacht die verdopplung zeit
zeigt etwas was bedeutet exponentielles
wachstum und was bedeutet lineares
wachstum war ja nicht jeder sich jeden
tag damit auskennt der faktor sagt das
auch ein erfolg torgleich 1 habe ich ja
hier erklärt ist immer wieder jeden tag
nennen die gleiche effekt infizierten
zahl die epidemiologen sagen er muss
unter 1 sein also die zahl der
infizierten muss zurückgehen und jetzt
kommen natürlich hinzu
denn wir 40.000 infizierte haben und
jeden tag 1500 neue infizierte
dann können 400 gesundheitsämter das
verfolgen das war schon immer das ziel
wo waren wir gut als bei webasto eine
chinesin 16 leute angesteckt hat da
haben wir jeden einzelnen fall verfolgen
können hätten wir das weiter so gemacht
hätte machen können während manche
maßnahmen nicht notwendig gewesen
irgendwann sind aber sehr viele
skiurlauber gekommen ist heinsberg der
karneval gekommen
dann ist das nicht mehr gelungen diese
einzelne infektionen nachzuvollziehen
und dann hat sich dieses exponentielle
wachstum eingestellt
jetzt müssen wir zurück im grunde zu dem
anfangspunkt dass wir jeden
nachverfolgen können wo hast du dich
angesteckt und wie ist das geschehen und
keine dieser zahlen ist falsch und wenn
wir jetzt nur ein gesundheits einleiten
und die müssen 1519 vierte nacht
vollziehen würde es natürlich nicht
gehen also haben wir gesagt wir müssen
alle öffentliche gesundheitsämter
qualifizieren verstärken
20.000 menschen ein team die das
nachvollziehen
und jetzt sind die gesundheitsämter viel
viel stärker wir haben es gemacht werden
dies und jenes gemacht und die meldewege
sind besser am anfang haben wir
überhaupt keinen überblick wie viel
intensivbetten wir haben inzwischen
haben wir ein register wo wir sagen
können liegt drin
wir haben fast 100 prozent der
intensivbetten jetzt erfasst
wir können jetzt mit teufel neue
operationen öffnen weil man die
durchschnittliche liegezeit hat man weiß
wann habe ich das bett wieder frei wir
haben also unglaublich viel jeden tag
gelernt und all die ziffern und zahlen
unterricht werde sind am anfang richtig
gewesen am ende richtig gewesen und es
bildlich zu machen stellt man sie zum
teil anders da und das ziel ist wie bei
webasto am anfang wieder da hinzukommen
jede infektionskette zu verfolgen
deshalb auch die tracing app und viele
andere sachen so ich glaube tschentscher
hätte es eigentlich noch viel besser
erklärt film war schon mal in frankreich
noch einmal eine ergänzung weil
wissenschaftler sind wissenschaftler und
keine
wir haben ein neues virus es gibt gab
keine belastbaren daten bisher
deswegen hat die wissenschaft annahmen
getroffen viele andere haben sich auch
schon bestätigt die übereinstimmung
wissenschaftlicher aussagen ist aus
meiner sicht viel größer als das das wir
an unterschieden derzeit haben und
worauf es jetzt ankommt ist das was die
bundesregierung vorbereitet hat wir
haben eine ganze reihe an systematischen
untersuchungen die jetzt in deutschland
laufen die auch einheitlich ausgewertet
werden sollen und bestimmte
fragestellungen die jetzt ganz speziell
bedeutsam sind möglichst bald zu klären
zum beispiel welche rolle spielen
kleinkinder bei der infektions
übertragung der hat rosten und andere
wissenschaftler haben ja zunächst einmal
eine annahme analogie schluss aus
ähnlichen virus gruppen und präsentiert
und daraufhin mussten wir aus
vorsichtsgründen sagen wenn das so ist
dann dürfen sie jetzt keinen fehler
machen aber jetzt beginnen die studien
darüber ganz konkret dieses virus welche
auswirkungen hat es wie für das
immunsystem stimuliert ist es werden
jetzt serologische studien gemacht um
festzustellen wie ist es mit jemandem
der die infektion überstanden hat hat
der antikörper schützen die vor einer
erneuten infektion
das kann man nicht zu hundert prozent
wissen derzeit und wissenschaftler sind
geübt darin das zu kontrollieren das zu
untersuchen
und sobald es dort eine sicherheit gibt
haben sie auch eine sichere
entscheidungsgrundlage für die politik
und solange müssen wir mit einer rest
unsicherheit leben wir können nur
aufgrund von daten entscheiden die es
gibt und deswegen bin ich sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir die nächsten
wochen einige dinge werden länger dauern
einige hinweise werden wir
wahrscheinlich etwas früher gekommen
aber wichtig ist dass man die daten
jetzt sammelt und dass man da wo sie
nicht von alleine entstehen sie auch
systematisch erhebt das ist natürlich
ein grundsätzliches prinzip wenn ich
etwas noch nicht weiß dass ich dann
nicht immer vom allerbesten fall
ausgehen wird schon gut gehen sondern
werde nie etwas nicht weiß ist die
vorsicht und die umsicht das gebot mit
dem ich am wenigsten
gefährde das ist einfach so und wir
haben wir eine gute
wissenschaftslandschaft wir haben jetzt
unsere wissenschaft wirklich auch die
universitätsmedizin gut ausgestattet die
forschungsleiter gut ausgestattet wir
tun ja alles und möglichst schnell
erkenntnisse zu bekommen
nächste frage herr schuler dahin gilt
eine frage knüpft da an
aus teilnehmerkreisen war zu hören dass
es auch unmut gegeben hat eben klagen
dass er sehr verständnisvoll mit dem
öffentlichen auftreten und der
selbstdarstellung einzelner
wissenschaftler namentlich herren
drosten
viele theorien haben sich dann lauf der
zeit ja wie sie haben selbst
angesprochen schon widersprochen
stimmt das gab es da kritik am
öffentlichen auftreten aber es ist halt
so ich glaube es gab es gab natürlich
den ihnen von den kernen dingen aber was
schon wichtig war ebenfalls nun zwar
wichtig das merken sie auch gerade an
den beiden engagierten vorträgen dass
wir schon einfach normalität den rahmen
klären
ich glaube dass wir die letzten wochen
in deutschland zum teil einer etwas
surreales debatte bekommen haben nicht
der wunsch der bürgerinnen bürger nach
veränderungen ist das problem sondern 90
argument in der politischen diskussion
die mehrzahl der bürger scheint
jedenfalls umfragen zufolge diesen
charakter vorsicht und umsicht ob er zu
bestätigen als überstürztes anderen und
wir sind man kann ihrem arzt keinen
vorwurf machen wenn wir jetzt den ersten
teil der haupt krise einer krankheit
überstanden hat und er gibt damit 2
privat schläge zur therapie kann man den
arzt nicht verantwortlich machen dafür
dass die krankheit gegeben hat wir
müssen jetzt schon einfach die
bundeskanzlerin sagte tschentscher wir
müssen jetzt bewerten was gibt es
wissenschaftliche vorschläge wie ist es
aus unserer sicht einzuschätzen zu
bewerten aber da eben und das ist
entscheidend
unsere wissenschaftler nicht nur in
ihrer klinik in deutschland forschen
sondern international erkenntnisse mit
einbeziehen ergeben sich auch
weiterentwicklung das ist der
entscheidende punkt
also ich kann doch eigentlich sagen wir
sind ein forscher land unsere gesamte
wirtschaftliche wohlstand basiert auf
innovation und auf wissenschafts
erkenntnis
ist eine der großen stärken deutschlands
deswegen sollten wir diese stärker im
bereich medizin behalten und wir waren
uns eigentlich alle einig dass man der
wissenschafts annahmen akzeptiert dass
wir damit umgehen muss politisch
entscheiden müssen politiker aber es ist
ein kluger und wichtiger ratschlag dies
nicht zu ignorieren und das ist ja ganz
ganz menschlich dass wir uns alle
wünschen dass wir schnell wieder
möglichst zu leben können wie bevor
dieses virus in unser leben eingetreten
ist und dass wir alle auch mit sorgen
natürlich die folgen sehen die dieses
virus anrichtet nicht nur beim menschen
sondern auch an unserer wirtschaft an
unseren sozialen kontaktmöglichkeiten an
familien die einschränkungen haben einen
kinder nämlich andere kinder sehen
können aber ich warne davor sozusagen
gehen bringer der botschaft
verantwortlich dafür zu machen dass der
wunsch nicht in erfüllung geht sondern
es ist wäre ganz schwierig wenn die
wissenschaftler sich nicht mehr trauen
das was sie wissen zu sagen und wir uns
dann in einer scheinsicherheit wiegen
die aber zum schluss nicht trägt und
deshalb glaube ich müssen wir politisch
entscheiden aber können dankbar sein
dass uns wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
mitgeteilt wird
und da sind unsicherheiten dabei das
liegt in der natur der sache deshalb des
wissenschaftlers so spannend weil man
nicht zweimal das gleiche macht man hat
immer was neues kenne ich ja noch von
früher dass in der politik nicht jeden
tags oder muss man manchmal das
wiederholen aber man hat auch immer
unbekanntes und das ist liegt und
deshalb sind wir ja politiker nutzer
müssen daraus die schlüsse ziehen
welche zwei fragen können wir noch
nehmen
herr winkel von reuters sie haben jetzt
alle drei ein sehr kontrollierten
prozess beschrieben aber gibt das nicht
ein akteur der nur ganz kurz von den
söder erwähnt wurde nämlich die gerichte
die ihnen eigentlich ein bisschen die
handlung schiene und die entscheidung
wie schnell geöffnet wird aus der hand
nehmen
ein beispiel 800 quadratmeter grenze
das ist in bayern gefallen hamburger
haben damit erfahrung macht mitgerechnet
sind heute bestimmt ist ja mit den noch
größeren geschäften die dann die
verkaufsfläche reduzieren müssen genau
was hat gerichtsentscheidungen gegeben
die politische entscheidung korrigiert
haben
die frage ist wie sehr besorgt sie das
dass sie auch bei den nächsten schritten
vor den gerichten letztlich eine
beschleunigung bekommen und was heißt
das für diese 800 quadratmeter grenze
wird die möglicherweise nächste woche
fallen
also wir leben in einem rechtsstaat
deswegen nehmen wir jede
gerichtsentscheidung nicht nur hin
sondern setzen wir uns
selbstverständlich
und das ist übrigens wie viele dinge
auch natürlich ein begleit maßstab
genauso wie das was in den
veröffentlichten meinung im presse im
parlament stattfindet das sind alles
argumente werden gewogen und auch
versucht umzusetzen
allerdings sei es auch relativ offen die
frage ob die 800 quadratmeter herunter
regeln oder für andere hoch regeln
darfst ist jetzt nicht die ganz
entscheidende frage
und ob man mal ein bundesland etwas eine
woche früher oder später macht ist nicht
das entscheidende
wir haben letztes mal über masken gebot
geredet dann haben viele länder ist
gemacht auch wir jetzt haben wir de
facto ohne masken pflicht ich glaube
dass das sogar das bleibt nicht stärker
an unserem land das nicht einmal etwas
verordnet wird von oben und es bleibt
sondern es ist ein schönes wort
kontrolliert der prozess genannt ja das
stimmt sein kontrollierter prozess und
zwar von allen seiten
die argumente die einige sagen das würde
hier völlig ohne jede kontrolle
stattfindet schlicht und einfach nicht
wahr und ich finde es gut dass der
rechtsstaat an der stelle auch immer
funktioniert der waister uns immer
wieder auf mögliche schwachstellen
übrigens auch von kompromiss
entscheidungen die 800 quadratmeter aber
keine liebes entscheidung oder aus
voller überzeugung es war eine komponist
entscheidung aus unterschiedlichen
erwägungen heraus
insofern glaube ich sogar dass er hilft
in dem prozess
das ist stört wenn man die urteile sich
nicht also sich durch die
urteilsbegründung gegen gerichte auch
sehr differenziert mit den
fragestellungen und wenn ich das jetzt
mal so aus meiner bewertung
sagen darf wir haben jetzt heute
nachmittag gerade das urteil jetzt noch
nicht genau gelesen aber ich hab das
kurz gesehen
das ovg in hamburg hat diese 800
quadratmeter klausel bestätigt weil sie
zwar einerseits als gericht sehen diesen
gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz die man ja
immer nachkommen möchte auf der anderen
seite räumen die gerichte dem start der
politik auch einen spielraum ein weil
man ja an erkennt die situation in der
wir uns bewegen dass wir uns
schrittweise vor bewegen müssen immer
auch beachten müssen dass die dinge
nicht außer kontrolle
laufen dürfen und dafür dann eben auch
manchmal zwischenschritte definieren
müssen da das leben aber ein kontinuum
ist gibt es immer wenn sie irgendwo eine
grenze setzen oder eine entscheidung
treffen begrenzt bereiche in denen man
aus gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz auch
andere meinungen haben kann und deswegen
sehe ich momentan schon dass die
gerichte die lage in der wir uns bewegen
schon anerkennen und in die
gesamtbewertung einbeziehen also wie
gesagt die 800 800 quadratmeter krenz
ist jetzt gerade in hamburg doch auch in
anderen ländern bestätigt worden was
aber nicht auf dauer so bleiben was
natürlich müssen wir immer wieder prüfen
wenn die dinge sich weiter entwickelt
haben
ob diese auflagen die wir haben aufrecht
erhalten werden müssen und deswegen sind
diese verfügung die wir beschließen auch
alle immer zeitlich sehr begrenzt es ist
ja gerade erwähnt worden dass wir jetzt
sagen nicht einmal für die nächsten drei
monate liegen wir etwas fest sondern wir
begrenzen die verfügung oder die
regelungen immer so dass wir also je
bedeutender sie sind und jeweils rechner
sie sind umso kürzer setzen wir sie in
kraft und signalisieren damit auch dass
wir immer engmaschiger prüfen ob sie
noch nötig sind oder ob wir sie eben
zugunsten einer
größeren lockerungen ersetzen können die
gerichtsurteile sind natürlich auch für
uns ansporn unsere entscheidung sehr
sehr gut zu begründen
wir haben ja die 800 quadratmeter die
schon ein kompromiss waren nicht deshalb
gewählt weil wir nicht glauben dass man
bei 850 quadratmetern nicht mehr im
laden den abstand machen kann sondern
wir haben gesagt wir wollen nicht den
gesamten personenverkehr in die
innenstädte
da sind die städte deutschlands auch
noch sehr unterschiedlich es gibt städte
die haben sehr kleine fußgängerzonen in
denen bald sich sehr schnell der kontakt
und wir müssen immer wieder überlegen
und viehhändler ja auch sagt das ändert
sich ja auch mit jeder weiteren
maßnahmen immer wider abwägen ist das
noch in relation zu anderen mehr war zum
beispiel jetzt auch wichtig dass wir
nicht den gesamten handel aufmachen aber
noch kein wort über kitas gesagt haben
das heißt wir müssen auch die
verschiedenen sektoren der gesellschaft
immer wieder bedenken weil sonst einer
sagt warum darf eigentlich der gesamte
handelsbereich schon voll arbeiten aber
ich habe in anderen bereichen die
gesellschaftlich natürlich auch von
größter relevanz sind noch gar nichts
und so müssen wir das eben immer wieder
gegeneinander abwägen und auch die
infektionsrisiken natürlich dabei
bedenken
letzte frage ruppert z
eine frage an alle drei bitte die kitas
sie haben sie eben angesprochenen die
schulen oder sie haben gesagt die
familie ist ganz wichtig haben sie heute
darüber gesprochen dass es perspektiven
gibt dass man vielleicht bundesweit zu
einer regelung kommt wann es dann wieder
losgehen kann es gibt ja länder die zum
beispiel die jüngsten die kleinsten
zuerst losgeschickt haben dänemark die
niederlande zum beispiel und wäre das
etwas wie zum beispiel deutschland auch
aus diesen erfahrungen etwas lernen
können und wäre das vielleicht ein
beispiel von meiner seite kann nur sagen
wir wollen ja gerade am mittwoch da ein
stück weiterkommen am 65 das war nicht
nur prinzipiell sagen wir wollen mal
wieder aufmachen sondern auch die
schritte wir haben ja bei den schulen
schon schritte vereinbart
die abschlussklassen dann ab vierten mal
die klassen die nächstes jahr
abschlussklassen sind und so wird man
sich jetzt auch durch handeln das müssen
die kollegen aus den ländern plate noch
stärker sagen ich glaube dass es kein
entweder-oder gibt nur die großen
schüler oder nur die kleinen sondern das
sind ja ganz unterschiedliche
einrichtungen das heißt ich muss gucken
wie komme ich mit den neuen abstands
geboten in einer kita klar
und wie komme ich mit den neuen abstands
geboten in einer schule klar und da gibt
es dann auch verschiedene schultypen
insofern glaube ich würde es in
deutschland eher ein paralleler prozess
der verschiedenen altersgruppen sein wo
aber nicht nie wieder einheit das cool
sofort 100 prozent all dessen hat was
vor der hungerkrise war also das wären
wir nächste woche diskutieren wir sind
bei uns mit unseren pädagogen und den
lehrern sehr engen austausch mit soldier
mann gilt als größte herausforderungen
weil die sensibilitäten
unterschiedlichsten sind die
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse auch am
entwickelten im sinne von vielleicht
vielleicht auch nicht
eines kann man glaube ich fest es wird
auch keinen veränderung alle schuljahren
werden so das ist glaube ich das
entscheidende und unser ziel muss sein
dass am ende die schule und schüler aus
diesem schuljahr kein nachteil für den
weiteren lebensweg und schuldig haben
das gilt sowohl für das thema
sitzenbleiben
das geht aber ganz besonders auch bei
den prüfungen also wir beispielsweise
bei uns glauben garantiert zu können
dass ein abi dass man dieses jahr macht
oder eine mittlere reife oder ein quali
die gleiche qualität schafft genau die
gleiche qualität wie sonst glaubt an 10
fallen muss die absolute normalität
erreicht werden aber kein notabitur oder
ähnliches mehr
aber sollten jetzt aber erstmal als als
et gab aber bei allen anderen klassen
muss man überlegen was der beste weg ist
und wie man das auch die interessen von
eltern die betreuung wollen den
interessen von eltern die große sorge
sind ihre kinder
wir kriegen also briefe auch die sagen
gar nicht mehr in die schule bringen wie
wir das alles zu organisieren wie der
schulfamilie dass es den breiten konsens
gibt ich befürchte wir waren nicht alle
glücklich machen können beim thema
schule
aber unser ziel ist vernünftige
schulstruktur mit den betroffenen zu
erreichen
wir haben ja jetzt aus den fachminister
konferenzen sehr sehr fundierte stufen
pläne für den bereich kita genauso wie
für die schüler
das heißt die fachlich ist genau jetzt
überlegt wie man schrittweise öffnen
kann
in den stufen steht aber noch kein datum
das müssen wir jetzt prüfen wie wir auch
zeitlich abgewogen zwischen den sektoren
vorgehen können und deswegen haben wir
glaube ich für nächste woche eine gute
grundlage und dass das so ambitioniert
doch ausgearbeitet ist zeigt einfach
dass wir da die interessen sehen und das
wird das nicht auf die leichte schulter
nehmen was gerade auch bei den jüngeren
kindern bei den kita und im bereich
jetzt dringend nötig ist
vielen dank dann wünsche ich noch einen
schönen ersten mal
[Musik]
ja